[Music]
[Music]
not today Playboy hello 900s I have an
emergency there is an aggressive spider
that refuses to leave my home did I
mention that the spider was on top of a
burglar not have any brain in this house
bug will stop me from watching TV no
just say my name our kid I know you
don't want to talk to me like that but
that's a you can't talk to me like that
anyway does Pam cooking spray kill
spiders look fan if you leave right now
just out the door I promise to never
kill any of your homies again bees flies
ants other arachnid peep things I'm
please leave I'm not going I'm not going
if a spider comes into your home okay
and they say hey I'm a spider I don't
care if I didn't get an invite this is
where I want to be what are you going to
do what are you going to do do your job
nothing huh aren't you sucking
Houdini bug game has changed what are
you doing don't want to talk about it
whatever makes you the briefcase man
[Music]
damn neck come on we gotta go gotta go
oh right the backpack got matches burn
it down come on bird yeah
[Music]